caitlyn jenner is running for governor
of california
are you with her are you with him
or are you like lot just planning to
flee california to the hills
lest you be swept away buckle up
buckaroos i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
buckle up buckaroo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from tarawa 1943 who says
wearing masks
is like the old 50s duck and cover
during the cold war
you will survive a nuclear blast by
getting under a wooden desk and eating
saltine crackers
yes there seem to be a lot of
similarities there and again i'm just
saying this because i follow the science
because of that peer-reviewed scientific
study that we read from the
nih website on the show last week so
look me i'm just following the science
duck and cover lots to duck and cover
about these days
if you look the way uh politics is going
notably in my former state
of california california is a golden
state that's where the gold rush
happened
and if you want physical gold i would
strongly recommend you check out acre
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30
a month you pay each month once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house acre has a new
100 a month subscription to a 5 gram
gold bar
lets you invest in physical gold without
coming out of pocket all at once i know
you think oh it'd be good to invest in
physical gold
but there's not enough change between
the couch cushions to make it happen
this is a brilliant way
to be able to do it they've also got a
brand new 24 karat gold nine millimeter
bullet
among the our nationwide ammo shortage i
would not recommend
actually shooting this bullet unless
you're aiming squarely at a werewolf
michael that's silver you don't know
you've never shot a werewolf head on
over to getacre
michael start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre
that is getacre gold.com michael thank
you
aker gold for supporting the show i'm in
she says he says it's very
it's confusing isn't it caitlyn says i'm
in
california is worth fighting for visit
caitlynjenner.com to follow
or donate today recall newsome
so are we for caitlyn or are we not for
caitlyn this is an open question on the
right
right now i don't i think it's skewing
in one direction but it's not totally
clear
there are prominent right wingers you
know i'm not just talking about squishes
i'm talking about prominent right
wingers
from the conservative wing of the
conservative movement who think the
caitlyn
candidacy is a good idea and there are
many other prominent conservatives who
say
i don't think so buddy this is a bridge
too far i think this is going to be a
good litmus test
for conservatives every so often litmus
tests pop up
trump in a way was a litmus test and i
think this is going to be
another good one there is a serious
argument on both sides there really is i
don't want a straw man i don't want to
dismiss this
out of hand no matter how funny it is
it would be really terrific if the first
woman governor
of california were a man that would be
really i would love that i think that
would give
a lot of conservatives who were sick of
the identity politics and the craziness
of the left i think
that would be a terrific thing however
if you're a man who thinks that you're a
woman
and who presents yourself as a woman
you are a seriously confused individual
it might not be a good idea to give you
a ton
of political power on the one hand
we could own the libs oh man
how owned would the libs be if
the first transgender governor who
says that he's a woman but he's not if
he were a republican
oh man the libs would be extremely owned
however
we might be owning ourselves by doing
that because
we would be owning the libs by adopting
their most
radical and cherished premises so it
might be a little bit of a pyrrhic
victory
yeah we get to claim this kind of funny
thing for a while in california and
caitlyn jenner cuts taxes and
gets tough on crime but at the cost of
what at the cost of
giving up the the basic distinction in
human nature doesn't seem like a great
idea
and then there's the political
consideration there's the buckley rule
the the william f buckley jr rule for
voting
was and is you vote for the most right
viable candidate so you vote for the
most
right-wing guy who can win an election
and in california somehow that
i guess there's a case to be made that
that's caitlyn jenner however the flip
side of that is
sometimes there's just got to be a line
in the sand
and conservatives we move that line back
and back and back and back and back but
a former member of the kardashian
family who is now
pretending to be a woman who
that might just be a step too far
ultimately i don't want to just sit on
the fence here you know i was on tim
poole's podcast
which we had such a great time on friday
night you can go check that out
and tim's critics they call him you're a
fence sitter and i think i don't think
that's really fair
but i don't want to be a fence sitter
here
i think it's too far i think the caitlyn
thing is too far
okay i think we have too much to lose
here
i don't like newsome i would like newsom
to lose
i think that caitlyn jenner actually
probably has fairly conservative views
on
a fair number of issues back when he was
bruce he used to come around to
conservative events in hollywood a fair
bit
it's just too far that if we win this
election
with caitlyn jenner and put caitlyn
jenner into office
we are exalting we are adopting as a
party as a conservative movement
transgenderism we are going to descend
into some
pitiful sort of political
rhetoric to say you know democrats are
the real transphobes
no i don't i don't think that we should
accept
the radical transgender ideology it's
not true
it's deeply harmful to society and if we
adopt
this sort of thing in our candidate for
governor of one of the largest states
in the country one of the largest
economies in the world if you were to
break it off separately
that would seem to me to be a big
problem but we don't have to do that
this
is not a binary choice i i
am of the opinion that the vast majority
of elections are binary choices you
remember in
in 2016 you heard a lot of people
conservatives who hated trump
they would say actually it's not a
binary choice we can vote for the egg
mcmuffin we can write and
i did not agree with that argument then
i thought no it's it's trump or hillary
make you gotta pick
okay no one seriously there's no other
candidate but in a recall election it's
not a binary choice
the way a recall election will work in
california is there will be a ballot
measure put up to the voters
and they will say should newsome be
removed but they've already got the
petitions they've already
been able to get past the threshold so
that the recall is up for the question
then you go and you vote and you say
should newsome be recalled
yes or no next question who should
replace him
because if more voters say he should be
recalled then say he shouldn't be
recalled
then they'll move to the next one who
should replace him and that's a pretty
wide open field
caitlyn jenner is i guess the most
famous candidate up right now
but there is a kevin falconer former
mayor of san diego
there's that guy cox he ran for
something or other there are other more
serious
more mainstream republicans than caitlyn
jenner
and with all of these candidates who
will be on the ballot
very likely the person who would win if
newsom
does not survive the recall question
will not have 50
of the vote so who's it going to be i
just
i i know it's glitzy it's funny you want
to own the libs
there's something fascinating and
hilarious about a caitlyn jenner
candidacy
there are other options republicans
there are other options the language
shows you the problem
because i was i was trying to keep an
open mind about this and i thought okay
what if he's really good on all these
questions and sure he's bad on the
transgender question but
he's probably no worse on the
transgender question than gavin newsom
is
but in his very candidacy you have the
problem of the transgender question
because how do we talk about him
i i'm not going to call him her i can't
do it because
he is not a woman and so i'm not going
to pretend that he is and
this isn't even a matter of personal
politeness if you're given to that sort
of thing where you say well you know
what a personal dinner party maybe i'll
refer to him as her but it's beyond that
we're talking about a major public
question here
and republicans aren't going to agree
i've spoken to many of my republican
friends over the past few days since
this news came out
some will call him him some will call
him here
the left controls society by controlling
language this is
the premise of my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
it's available now for pre-order while
you can still get it
if we are not united in fighting this
very subtle linguistic strategy if we
ourselves actually help to advance the
confusion
that does not seem to be in our
long-term interest joy behar that lady
on the view
fell into this problem when when she was
announcing that
caitlyn jenner is running for governor
she referred to him
as him sonny he's got this guy brad
pascal
running his campaign what do you think
about that i mean that guy
was was accused of using uh campaign
funds to enrich himself what that's
who's running his campaign
or her campaign rather i would go along
with that i think that he
should she rather should take a seat
and let somebody with the credentials
take over a major state like california
so i've never said this before but joy
behar i think is a good example of most
of america
who i i don't think that joy behar did
this intentionally i don't think this
was
a subtle dig you know she kept
correcting herself she said
yeah and i don't think he should i mean
she i'm sorry she
maybe it was a subtle dig at the
transgender thing but i think
more likely joy behar woman of a certain
age remembers bruce jenner the guy's
been famous for a very long time
and he's the most famous athlete in the
world he's the first woman to win the
decathlon
right and we've all known him as he
since he was on the wheaties box
and over the last few years he's
pretending to be she but
for people who remember him it's you
can't do that
it's very difficult to do that so what
does joy behar do
she apologizes so first of all let me
apologize for my pronoun mix-up i i
think i just didn't get enough sleep
last night i had no intention of uh
mixing them up but and i tried to
correct it immediately but
whatever it just came out so i'm sorry
if anybody was upset by that
i can't belie i can believe that she had
to apologize this apology didn't sound
particularly sincere to me she was like
i mixed it up come on give me a break
if you're offended whatever i'm sorry
i have heard conservatives self i don't
question how conservative they are but
self-styled conservatives
have referred to the misgendering
of caitlyn jenner misgendering is a
leftist term
that that refers to when you call a man
a man
but if the man thinks he's a woman and
you call him a man that's called
misgendering
now of course the the more precise term
would be gendering
the the only people misgendering bruce
jenner are the people who are caitlyn
jenner now
are the ones who were referring to him
as her but even some
self-styled right-wingers are adopting
this language
even some stealth self-styled
right-wingers are saying no really come
on to be polite
we should refer to him as her quite the
opposite actually
quite the opposite it's disrespectful to
refer to him as her no it's not
it's disrespectful to treat him like a
complete lunatic and indulge his
fantasies and say oh yes you really are
a woman
sir lady whatever no the truth is
respectful
can be harsh sometimes and euphemisms
try to
sugarcoat harsh truths but the truth is
respectful
and lies are very disrespectful you
don't lie to people that
you respect you certainly don't
habitually lie to them as as in the case
of referring to
caitlyn jenner as a as a woman
this this idea very prominent on the
left now
that that lies are compassionate and the
truth is cruel that is
a wicked totally backwards idea
and if conservatives adopt that we're
lost we are totally lost
and there therein lies the real poison
of the gender candidacy you're already
seeing some conservatives adopt this
language you gotta
stop this before it gets too far
regardless of how the california
election turns out
caitlyn jenner is more the norm
in this regime than the average
conservative is
yes oh we think caitlyn jenner is a
sideshow
a reality tv star a famous athlete going
back many decades
who's now making even more of a
spectacle of himself
he is much more the norm he is much more
accepted by the dominant liberal regime
than you deplorable people are you
deplorable
irredeemable bible thumping bitter
clinging
middle americans you are considered
the oddity you are considered the
bizarre
you should be part of the circus caitlyn
jenner no he's just a man
following his true self because he's
trapped inside the wrong body or
whatever
this is the dominant ideology it goes by
the name
lgbt right now even
this this initialism doesn't make any
sense
because the logic for the l and the g
totally undermines the logic for the t
the logic for the l and the g is i'm
born this way i have certain sexual
desires
you can't change these sexual desires
it's it's very wrong to
shame people for their desires and so
come on you know let
when boys from a very early age are
attracted to other boys just come on let
them do it right okay i
totally understand that logic the logic
of the t
is actually no there's no such thing as
innate sex there's no forget innate
sexual desire there's no such thing as
innate sex
it sex is totally socially constructed
there's really no difference between a
man and a woman
and therefore a man can be a woman
very easily just by saying so that logic
undercuts
the other logic now there is a little
bit of a connection here
in that the gender ideologues took
one of the claims of the t took one of
the claims of the l and the g
and brought it to a radical conclusion
and that claim is that
for the logic for instance of gay
marriage
the claim here is that man plus man
equals man plus woman right that's the
equal sign that these are exactly the
same thing there's no distinction
whatsoever sexual difference has nothing
to do with marriage
so if you just do a little basic math
here
if m plus m equals
m plus w then that means you take out
some of the m's here you're kind of
mixed around
that m equals w it means that men and
women are indistinguishable
by the logic of redefining marriage so
then what the transgender idiot
ideologues do is they take that and they
say okay well if men and women are
indistinguishable then
bruce jenner can become caitlyn jenner
and he can he can now become she and
there's no
no problem here it's it's obviously very
convoluted it's a little bit complex but
this is the state
ideology now i mean i mean that actually
is a matter of state policy the
secretary of state anthony
blinken has now given blanket approval
for u.s
embassies and consulates around the
world to fly the
rainbow lgbt pride flag on the same
polls as the american flag i have long
said
that the rainbow flag is a symbol of
american imperial hegemony
it seems like it's this radical thing
what are you talking about radical
it is a symbol of the dominant liberal
regime it is as mainstream as it gets
think about all the many flags we've had
in our nation's history
we've got uh the gadsden flag
don't tread on me are you going to fly
that on the same pole as
the american flag at embassies around
the world no you you couldn't do that
you'd get in trouble for that i bet
what about the appeal to heaven flag the
pine tree flag washington's flag
would you fly that no that'd be there'd
be a big problem because of separation
of church and state
and you're not allowed to make moral
claims on the on the flag oh that'd be
that
would cause such an uproar wouldn't it
but the lgbt
rainbow flag yes that one flies
which in certain more conservative
countries particularly in the muslim
world
is a real finger in the eye doesn't
matter this has become a matter of
liberal global imperial policy
so expect the mainstream regardless of
what happens in california
expect the mainstreaming of the t at
least from the regime
at least as long as the radical left
wields political power because they
spent many decades
engaging in a war of position that gave
them positions of power that they could
then wield even though the majority of
americans i think
doesn't really go in for this stuff i
don't think the majority of americans
really believes that caitlyn jenner is a
woman
but the people who are in power are
willing to
push that ideology and they're doing it
very very successfully speaking of
flags and bad foreign policy joe biden
along with several other world leaders
more than several
took took part in this global climate
conference
last week there was a screen shot going
around
of all these world leaders you got putin
in the center you got all these
different guys from all around the world
and you got joe biden off on the side
and joe biden is the only one in the
screenshot wearing a mask i think it's
about 17 world leaders from this
conference they're all
sitting in their rooms they're on a zoom
call practically
and there is joe biden wearing a mask so
embarrassing
so he doesn't give kovit to his computer
or
what the biden defenders will say is
well so he doesn't give kovid to the
staff in the room
joe biden has been inoculated joe biden
has the vaccine
joe biden is not everyone can have the
vaccine at this point
certainly all the people around biden so
it's just for sure it's just a
ridiculous pathetic
weak show but that's not even the worst
part of this conference
what what nobody is really pointing out
very few people
is not that he's the only leader in the
picture wearing the mask
he's the only world leader in the
picture without his own country's flag
behind him
that's the crazy thing every other
leader has
their political flag behind them but not
joe biden
because we as a country hate ourselves
now and we
we protest the flag it is now mainstream
on the left
to protest the american flag whether
it's on a football field whether it's
elected politicians
in solidarity with those radical stupid
athletes like colin kaepernick
we don't like that whether it's on nike
shoes the betsy ross flag is not allowed
on shoes anymore
the american flag has now become a
partisan symbol
used to be though everyone waved the
flag everyone was
we disagree on where the country's going
but we all love the country that's over
the left doesn't love the country barack
obama famously said he wants to
fundamentally transform it
so he was at least honest about it and
now they rarely even wave the flag
what you're really seeing i think when
you see the american flag and the lgbt
flag
on the same poll is even less a question
of sex
and more a question of nationhood versus
universal claims
the american flag is a defense of the
nation proper
the lgbt flag is a defense of
universal borderless ideology floating
in the sky it's just about who we are as
people
and our desires that can apply to anyone
at any time
the american flag is the flag of a
nation the lgbt flag is an imperial flag
making claims about everyone all over
the world
that i think is the real distinction
here and so biden
didn't have the lgbt flag behind him
that would have been even even funnier
but like but also he would not have the
american flag behind him either because
the
left in this country is very
uncomfortable making any sort of
national claims they want to get rid of
our borders
they want to get rid of a foreign policy
that prioritizes our own citizens
interests
they want to
administer this liberal imperial world
government all of this putatively about
climate change
but climate changes of course there was
global cooling there was global warming
then there was a pause and now it's
climate change and that's the climate
crisis they change the words but there's
always the same
answer which is give away more and more
of our political powers we the people
but then give away even our national
power to international and supernational
institutions that are going to govern
not just us but kind of govern everybody
this propaganda is being pushed not just
at the political
geopolitical level it's being pushed on
nickelodeon nickelodeon dedicated a show
to describing why it's so important to
take care of the environment because not
just of the trees and the birds and the
fish
but because of environmental racism
black snow the thick soot that pollutes
pahokee florida
there's cancer alley which is an area
along the mississippi river in louisiana
that's lined with oil refineries and air
so toxic in new york south bronx that 20
percent of children
have asthma what do these cities have in
common
they're all examples of environmental
racism
a form of systemic racism where minority
and low-income communities
are surrounded by health hazards because
they live near sewage
mines landfills power stations major
roads
in philadelphia it's hazardous waste in
san carlos arizona
it's a mining project that would
dishonor an apache sacred site
but it has never been more devastating
and harmful
than in duplin north carolina where
believe it or not
the number of hogs outnumber
the number of residents my name is fiona
i grew up in duplin county north
carolina fiona moved away from duplin
county as soon as she could
which is why she's okay opening up about
life there okay hold on did you see the
issue
all of their claims they're building up
to which is they're really dubious
claims that
in in poor areas you're seeing
different demographic groups who are
disproportionately poor uh those areas
are not as nice as rich areas
okay yup makes it not exactly
groundbreaking stuff and this
constitutes environmental racism i'm not
totally buying into that
and it's it's all about race and the
races are stuck there and then the woman
says
yeah i moved away as soon as i could ah
wait right you can just move away
you can just leave you can go somewhere
else i'm not saying it's easy to go
somewhere else but you can
okay you're not you're not locked down
you're not chained there
the reason they have to talk about
environmental racism though is because
we've lost
our moral discourse we can't we can't
talk about the objective moral order we
can't really talk about good and evil
and right and wrong because the left is
undermined
belief in those things so the the only
the only way we can talk about evil now
is by calling it racism racism is the
ultimate expression of evil
even when it has nothing to do with race
like you're talking about the
environment
and areas that have more pollution than
other areas but you have to call it
racism in order to and and that's also
because
we've lost our ability to have
metaphysical discourse so we've only got
to talk about physical things
so the the evil things have to do with
just they have to only go skin deep
total nonsense trying to get at a
a bizarre perversion of what all of
politics ultimately comes down to which
is yeah some things are good some things
are bad some things are right
some things are wrong but we're not
we're not allowed to say that anymore
because we we've embraced this radical
subjectivism of the left which is by the
way
much the subject of my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which
which you can pre-order right now
there's a special way to pre-order it
you can text speechless two five
three four four five
that's right five three four four five
you can pre-order a signed copy and
enter to win
a zoom call with me that's like
listening to my podcast
but live and then we can we'll be able
to chat on zoom uh text speechless to
five three four four five you know i was
on
i was on tim pool's podcast i mentioned
that earlier and
one of the funniest things we did was we
took super chats those questions from
the audience
and many many of you wrote in and
actually had to you know pay a couple
bucks to do it
to uh to plug my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
and we wondered is this because of a
sort of pavlovian reaction with the bell
going off and then but it was really
amazing we really appreciate it because
the book has been doing really well in
pre-sales it's
you know the book doesn't come out for
something like two months and it was
already
floating around i don't know number
three thousand on 2000
on all of amazon of all books even books
that are out have been out for a long
time
and by the time we got to the end of tim
poole's show i think it was around
number 400 on all of amazon it's
unheard of and isn't coming out for a
long time so anyway thank you very much
i appreciate that and i will look
forward to
zooming with you for anyone who texts
speechless253
445. also we've got another high energy
episode of candace coming at you this
friday
this week candace hosts political
commentator and interviewer
dave rubin where they will have a lot to
discuss including the recall election of
gavin newsom
his new opponent caitlyn jenner you can
subscribe now
stream candace live on fridays at 9 pm
eastern 8 pm central only on daily wire
and get 25 off a new membership with
code candace at dailywire.com
subscribe head on over to daily wire
we'll be right back with a lot more
the creepy environmental ideology
was distressing to watch joe biden
is the only guy on screen the only world
leader wearing the mask
in a room for a zoom call that's sad
everything has to go through the
environment
watching the creepy nickelodeon cartoons
talking about environmental racism it's
this new
religion it's a religion where we
worship mother earth and it's a
really inverted religion because we're
no longer worshiping the creator
we're worshiping the creation the libs
who are pushing this are probably not
even totally aware of that but that is
the effect of what they're doing
but somehow it gets worse somehow our
our scientistic religion
gets even more depressing because
this the religion needs a high priest
who's the high priest dr fauci of course
the new york times posted a video fairly
highly produced video
for the fouchy awards they had a
presenter
you know pretty good background these
are awards to
public health officials given around the
same time as the oscars which nobody
also watched from new york
it's the fountain awards 2020.
good evening and welcome to the fouchies
we're following social distance rules of
course so no
audience tonight but we won't let that
stop us from celebrating our
extraordinary public health officials
they're the doctors and scientists who
keep our water clean our
restaurants safe they stop outbreaks of
disease and
even keep mosquitoes from taking over
and in 2020 there are front line defense
against cobit 19. so what better year
than this
to celebrate their life-saving public
service
by giving out some of these
okay this isn't real there's no glitzy
ceremony
for any of these people there never was
instead
they're getting a lot of this this mask
mandate is ridiculous
he doesn't know what he's talking about
we better show them some recognition and
fast
so you know what we're gonna do this
thing
from new york it's the fountain awards
2020.
so i i actually will get into one little
segment that they go into but first
i have to point out that i do not know
what is more embarrassing
the fact that the libs have now made an
actual
golden idol of dr fauci a full
on bottom of mount sinai
bacchanalian rare a loss of faith and
apostasy to dr fauci
or how few retweets this video got
by the time i found actually sweet
little alisa found this video by the
time i looked at it
it had 13 retweets and it had been up
for 24 hours they spent a fair bit of
money making that video
and then they posted it and they're
so out of touch with the american people
that they don't realize how crazy that
is
my making fun of that video amassed more
retweets within like 20 minutes
than their their video actually did for
the whole past day
but then then the new york times did not
just leave it there
and make this little snide point of uh
we don't even we don't even recognize
our health care workers
we spent the past year worshiping at the
altar of these eggheads
who generally got things wrong and
certainly violated our constitutional
rights and upended our american way of
life
we've been worshiping them nonstop for a
year we don't give them any credit
oh doctor fancy you know what's so sad
but then they actually give out the
awards
dr mark wallace is everything you want
in a public health official
25 years of experience in weld county
colorado and a great communicator
in april with cases skyrocketing at a
meatpacking plant he pressured the
company to close the factory
all this while facing pressure from
politicians to reopen the county
this rural community is lucky to have dr
wallace's leadership
this is so creepy this is the creepiest
thing it goes on for six minutes
but do you hear what the times is saying
beneath all this
weird passive aggressive sort of they're
trying to make a joke
stuff what they're saying is
this egghead who had been appointed but
was basically unaccountable to the
people it's not like he's elected it's
not it's not as though he's part of the
ordinary run of constitutional
government
he fought valiantly to take away
the rights of the people in his county
even when the people in that county did
not want to give it up
even when the politicians that is the
elected representatives of the people
wanted him to stop his draconian
measures
he valiantly fought on to undermine
our american way of life take away our
rights
and lock people in their homes wow
how brave this guy totally deserves an
award
that is what they're saying it's no
surprise that the video got very few
retweets and very few views it's because
the the premise of the video is that the
people are bad
except for a handful of special people
who are the high priests of secular
progressivism
who because of how evil and stupid the
people are
these eggheads need to be protected from
democratic accountability
and they need to be allowed to totally
undermine our way of life in our
government
and the ones who succeeded at doing that
deserve special awards
and furthermore the applause of the
people
who they are set up explicitly in this
video
as existing to antagonize
that's that's what they think that's
what they believe when you hear about
the deplorables and the irredeemables
and the bitter clingers that's what
they're saying
people rotten therefore our
constitutional government has to be
rotten because it
derives its power from the people
therefore it has to be upended and we
need to create a new special secret
government
and you can call it the deep state you
can call it the administrative state you
can call it
progressive technocracy whatever that
you need a government of fouchies
to take over for these rube idiot people
have we exhausted our constitutional
system of government
it seems like we've reached a stage of
decadence where the people really can't
fight back and we're
the best that the ostensibly
conservative party can muster
is a man who thinks that he's a woman
who's
whose greatest claim on being able to
govern
is that he was on television with the
kardashian family
this is not good the left plays for
keeps they play to win they've done a
good job of massing power
what do we do we we criticize it a
little bit we
usually most of the time we don't even
really know what we're criticizing
and then on the rare occasion we get
political power we refuse to wield it we
refuse to exercise it
that is not a serious country there are
very few people left in public life
who i think represent that old idea of
what it means to be an american what a
american what it means to be a man what
it means to be a
person living in civilization
with the desires and the attitude that
helped us
get to where we are right now one of
those guys that one of those guys who
gives me hope
is elon musk elon musk
who wants to build a bunch of crazy cars
and wants to send people to mars
and wants to half the time i don't know
if the guy's a monorail salesman like in
the simpsons you know if he's like
totally full of it
or if he can actually bring the goods
and it actually seems like he delivers a
lot of the time
elon musk was just asking about this
trip to mars or rather he was asked by
an interviewer about this trip to mars
and it seems like there's some
logistical issues right now right we
can't i mean we can't even build a
a railway in california anymore we're
gonna have a super rail
connecting all the parts of california
now it ends up being this tiny little
railway between two towns that nobody
even goes to
we can't do it because that's too hard
it costs too much it's too dangerous
let's do this let's do that
so elon is asking okay how are you
supposed to get to mars and he says oh
well it's going to be extremely
dangerous and unpleasant and a bunch of
people are going to die
go to mars reads like that ad book for
shackleton going to the antarctic
you know it's it's dangerous uh it's
uncomfortable
um it's a long journey you might not you
know come back alive
um but it's a glorious adventure and
it'll be amazing an amazing experience
and your name will go in history yes
you might be uncomfortable and then you
probably won't have good food and
all these things you know so if
if an arduous and dangerous journey
where you may not come back alive um but
it's a glorious adventure
sounds appealing and mars is the place
and you still have
thousands of volunteers if not millions
of volunteers who would want to go
i mean honestly a bunch of people
probably will die in the beginning
it's tough sledding over there we're an
exploring species
yeah yeah exactly not forever we don't
make anyone go so it's
volunteers only he's totally right he's
getting a bunch of negative headlines
right now you're saying elon musk is
laughing about people dying
and exploration a lot of people are
going to die
when we try to colonize mars if if we
ever do that
that's just what happens when the
mayflower landed
in new england and this was well into
the age of exploration it's not as
though they were the first guys to check
out america
when they landed in new england half of
them died within the winter
right this is what happens when you go
to foreign places and you explore
it's arduous it's tough and you're going
to die and what elon is showing us right
now
is that there is a way of living that is
very different than the way that we're
living in now
right now it seems that most people are
living to craft
a perfectly pleasant and ultimately
meaningless existence
that is what connects all of these
various things the complaints about
grievance the demands for more gut money
from the government the the demands to
be coddled by big technology
the the demands that we pretend that
caitlyn jenner is a woman
and that we indulge everybody in their
fantasies what this is about
is saying look there's no real meaning
in the world there's no objective truth
there's no
there's no objective anything that we
ought to do we just want to
feel good in this very
elementary way in this very childish way
we just kind of want to feel good and so
whatever's going to make us
feel good that's what we should do very
often this is described as the moral
maxim of our
era if it feels good do it and you see
it across all sorts of policy
that idea that decadent and hedonistic
idea
is not what built the west it's what is
destroying the west but it's not what
built the west
the idea that built the west is that
there is objective truth
there is objective reality there are
unexplored
lands we want to know things in order to
know things you need to acknowledge that
there's an objective reality that you
can know about
and that there is more to life than
feeling
really pleasant all the time there is
more to life than just
extending your life so much the whole
public discourse of the past year is
about how we can avoid getting a cough
it's a it's about ultimately how we can
avoid death
even if you're very very old even if
you're very very sick
how you can avoid because death is
unacceptable how we can pretend that
we're never going to die
we didn't used to live just to avoid
death we used to accept that we're all
going to die and we're going to die soon
and i'm not not saying tomorrow
necessarily though you might
but i don't you're gonna let's say you
die in 30 years
40 years let's say you die in 70 years
it's not that much time
so if you're if you're going to live
just to not die
you're going to be disappointed you're
going to lose that battle you're going
to have a tragic ending
if you're going to live for something
else if you think that there's more to
life than just
breathing then you could have a great
glorious adventure
like elon musk is saying or
you could deny all of the hard
facts about the world you could deny
that you're going to die you could deny
that you're a man because you want to be
something else
do we want to live in reality or do we
want to live
in delusion do we want to do something
with this life
that we've been given or do we just want
to make ourselves feel good every so
often
which by the way you're not that doesn't
last forever it's like it's like doing a
drug you might feel good briefly but
you're going to have a hangover you're
going to have the
withdrawal you're going to have the
addiction if what's the line from c.s
lewis i mentioned this on tim poole's
podcast
if you look for truth you might find
comfort in the end but if you look for
comfort you'll find neither truth nor
comfort
only soft soap and wishful thinking to
begin and in the end
despair so don't despair look for
something
else there is a little bit of pushback
on this crazy lockdown regime that we're
still seeing all around us
we're now on the 700 millionth day of 15
days to slow the spread right
and it's supposed to go on longer and
longer and longer and longer
we're now being told we need vaccine
passports even if you're young even if
you're healthy
some people are pushing back believe it
or not in the united kingdom
thousands of protesters saturday marched
through london
to express their frustration with the
kovid 19 restrictions
including the vaccine passports they
gathered for a
unite for freedom protest centered
around demanding a ban
on the passports the lymeys are really
showing us up
they are i thought americans were
supposed to do this sort of thing but
we've lost that
you know we were talking the pat last
week about the anglo-saxon political
tradition
and the people on the left were calling
that racist or some something stupid
and they're saying there is no
anglo-saxon political tradition uh
that that is the anglo-saxon you watched
it in real time on saturday
the anglo-saxon political tradition is
not
tolerating the sort of outrageous
incomprehensible incoherent tyranny that
you're seeing around
the vaccine issue and the wu flew
americans could perhaps learn a thing or
two from the motherland on this point
what happened are we really going to
roll over on this
are we we're just going to the minute
they tell you well you can't go into
this bar
unless you have your vaccine passport
i don't know it's going to be really
tricky i mean if they tell you that you
if if they're able to get this through
then they're going to be able to
pressure a lot of people to do it
but if we push back really hard right
now and say no
absolutely not maybe you have a chance
to hold up i mean
we are the global hegemon right we are
the world power
if joe biden came out today and said hey
we're not doing vaccine passports
foreign countries you want you want to
demand a vaccine passport you're not
going to get american tourists
you're not going to get american
business hey
stay if at the state level the states
say we're not doing vaccine passports
like ron desantis has been doing
you'll see that build you know courage
is a prerequisite for all of the other
virtues
and virtue is a habit need
need to do that we need to get it i
don't think we should be violent i don't
think we should be
do anything immoral i'm no maxine waters
but i do think we need to speak up the
only time that americans are allowed to
get out in the streets these days of
course is when a leftist politician
incites riots
then covet is suspended it actually
helps to stop the spread of covid
if you get out and you burn down
buildings and you steal nike sneakers
it's not just maxine waters calling for
this stuff it's kamala harris it's
race-baiting cynical kamala harris
who actually what she did is worse than
what maxine waters did maxine waters
does not have a whole lot going on
between her ears okay i don't think
there's
a ton of brain cells rubbing together in
that old noggin of hers so she's very
clumsy with the way that she calls for
violence
she says get on them get in the
republicans faces
go to their house okay very clumsy
what kamala does is subtler but it's
more radical
she bails the riders out of jail that's
what she did last year in minnesota
she says you got to stay in the streets
always gives yourself a little plausible
deniability
now she's keeping it up on the derrick
chauvin trial they
the jury implausibly sends this man to
prison for
murder seems implausible to me
does kamala say okay good we got our
revenge that's good no she says
not enough nine minutes and 29 seconds
right we all watch that video many of us
watched it multiple times
and people are in pain
over what we all saw in that video
and um in fact it was
in large part because of that case that
together with
my then colleagues cory booker in
particular and then on the house side
karen bass that we wrote the george
floyd
justice and policing act there is no
question that
we've got to put an end to these moments
where
the public questions whether there's
going to be accountability
questions whether is going to be the
kind of fairness that that we should all
expect and deserve
in all of our lives and in particular as
it relates to
people of color with a particular
emphasis on black and brown men
in the criminal justice system as it
relates to policing this verdict is but
a piece of it and it will not
heal the pain that existed for
generations that has existed for
generations it will not heal as she goes
on and on and on
people should not have to question their
faith in the justice system
they're questioning it because dishonest
people like you
are spreading lies about it that's why
they're questioning it
because their leaders in the major
political party in the dominant regime
are undermining faith in that system so
that you can revolutionize that system
that's why they're doing it
and we know it and you know it and you
know that we know it
but it doesn't matter because you got
the power lady that's
and that's that's what really matters
she's got the power and she's willing to
exercise
it she is keeping this alive she is
taking what is a tote what she
previously or what
other politicians of her party
previously said was the total victory
the conviction on all accounts of derek
chovin this was supposed to be the proof
that the justice system does still work
and she says no but it doesn't
still doesn't not good enough never good
enough
sorry got to stay in the streets
got to keep bailing those riders out of
prison got to keep giving us
the pretext the crisis the pretext to
upend the whole system i will have to
give credit where credit's due
tweedledee and tweedledum over there on
cnn don lemon
and and chris cuomo came they came out
they actually
defended that cop who who shot makia
bryant as she was inches away from
stabbing that other girl
and they caught some flack for that they
went back on tv
and doubled down and also what happened
with the
shootings what's going on with that
that's really important that we discuss
and i think we had a very important
uh and illuminating conversation last
night that the whole country
uh is having and i think we should
continue to have those conversations
because uh it is what resonates with the
american people
and it's what people want to see change
and they also want to know
how quite frankly how to feel about it
and what
and what can be done about it and what
their fellow americans are saying and
thinking about it
and i still stand by that we cannot
treat all police shootings
with the in the same way they're not
right they're 100 not equal
and the i the poor mom that you had on i
feel for her but not every police
shooting is the same
and we have to look at the evidence and
what we know imagine if the woman in the
pink
was your loved one and the officer
didn't do what he did
you could be mourning the death of that
woman that young lady in the pink
a little bit of honesty i want to give
credit where credits do a little bit of
honesty a little glimmer of hope
that all is not completely lost in this
political system
but i think probably you had better
buckle up buckaroos because this is
going to be a very very bumpy ride if
we're going to try to
salvage it i'm michael noel's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy bourie our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. on the matt well show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show